I spoke to the health surgery Matt
Hancock about social distancing using
face masks and all the confusion about
leaving the lockdown we can see one
person in the park can it be a different
person every day yes
greater than 2 meters yes at greater
than 2 meters so outside being outside
is safer than being inside but it is not
zero risk so we are making some baby
steps
some relaxations but we're doing it very
very carefully basically because we
don't our rate to get above 1 and the
impaction to get out of control ok so
inside I can't I can't see my sister but
I can't see my cleaning lady well again
if you have somebody like a cleaner
coming to your house then they should
exercise social distancing and obviously
follow the other good practices that we
can't forget you know the basics washing
your hands is incredibly important
keeping surfaces clean so that the
infection isn't on it grandparents then
inside can't see their grandchildren but
they can see their carers the children
well again this is all about protecting
people so often we know that it's just a
matter of scientific fact that the over
seventies are more vulnerable to this
disease and so it is therefore common
sense that we should do everything we
can to protect those who are more
vulnerable there's then another a
further group that we've talked about on
this program that clinically extremely
vulnerable who we say you shouldn't meet
anybody but yes this is all about
applying and straightforward rules with
common sense ever based on the facts
about this disease that we do know like
that it's spread less outside but still
does and we've got quite a lot of
rattles through so we get that but you
get the point that I'm making and the
point is that family members you can
employ as your cleaning team and that's
okay with the rules grandparents can be
employed as carers of grandchildren
that's okay with the rules but you can't
have them as your sister or your
grandparents come to see you in the
house you can see why it's confusing no
I I'm afraid I disagree with that and
the principles are really clear and the
public have been really sensible so far
and this is why an appeal to people's
common sense is is very very sensible in
there herself
and that's a break with a great British
public have really understood what
social distancing means why we need to
do it sadly I nobody wants social
distancing rules but because they are
important the principles are outside is
better than inside stay two metres away
wash your hands and clean the surfaces
and see as few people as you can and
outside of your household because that
virus spread